hallo mein name ist luca und wir reden
heute mal wieder mit dem clever baut wie
eventuell wisst habe ich ja ein buch
herausgebracht wo ich ein paar minecraft
und text über mich und so alles mögliche
alles klar war es klar
jedenfalls wollte ich den clever bat
heute mal so ein paar fragen über das
buch stellen beziehungsweise was er
davon hält ob er schon hart ob er es
noch haben will ob ich dem
unterschreiben soll ob dieses tores von
sex und kommerz und auch mit kugeln und
es explosiv zusammen
ein muss für alle meine spieler und
crafter fans dabei habe ich wieder ein
bisschen mit ihm geredet wie ein
bisschen in schwung zu kriegen arbeit
natürlich die anfangs frage die wir dem
clever bot immer stellen was ich
allerdings in der letzten folge
vergessen habe welche farbe hat mein
shirt lieber clever bot mal schauen ob
es diesmal richtig weiß einmal oder
zweimal das richtig gewusst jetzt ich
schreib mal es ist nicht grau ich gebe
dir noch einen versuch mal schauen ob es
jetzt hinkriegt ich würde auch bei
taktik stimmt ich sollte mich echt
schämen für diese frage fangen wir an
kennst du contractor erstmal sonst eine
einleitung war schon aber mich überhaupt
kennt kann er auch sein dass acht enkel
also wenn ich clever bot hair colour bei
google eingeben kommt sowas hier
da sind ca die farben gar keine haare zu
brauen zu ping zu grün ist alles
vorhanden
deswegen schreibe ich einfach mal du
hast eine bunte haare mir geht es
genauso clever bot auch dunkelblonde
haare und ich hatte auf jeden fall auch
lieber grüne haare damit viele ja
teilweise gar nicht mehr dem kontakter
kennt sondern unter luka einfach weil
kontrast das so lange und das minecraft
mit und ich mache eigentlich gar nicht
mehr soviel minecraft und der grund ist
scheißegal frage ich einfach mal kennst
du luca ich meine das ist jetzt auch im
namen vielleicht denkt er an irgendeinen
anderen bekommen nicht mal an mich
er überlegt mit tatsächlich schon ein
bisschen zu lange bei dieser frage hier
gerade der ist immer noch einmal sinken
die antwort auf die frage kennst luca
ist
will der mich berichtigen gerade kannst
du ihn ja man das ist mein okay alles
klar kennst du sein buch fragezeichen
das wäre was soll ich tun
sein buch kennen also besitzt du kein
buch doch ich besitze ein buch und ich
möchte dich fragen ob die das eventuell
haben möchtest du davon hält ob du das
kennst ob du das nicht kennst du das
eventuell sogar schon hast lieber clever
oder besser ganz gut zu wissen ob sie
überhaupt schon irgendwas ich auch und
ich habe dich rein geschrieben
ich habe gerade das ganze buch durch
geguckt und es steht nahezu nirgendwo
clever dort drin
ich sehe gerade der clever bot meint
dass er ein buch hat und er mich in
seinem buch eine stimme deswegen frage
ich einfach mal könnte ich ein exemplar
von deinem buch erhalten einfach songs
rein wissenschaft da diese eigentlich
ganz gute überleitung zu minecraft
findest du in meinem buch übrigens vor
das ist jetzt kein irgendwie werbe
minecraft finde ich cool und cod sogar
das ist kein placement oder irgendwie so
wo ich bezahlt werde vom mit fast ins
gesicht gehabt wo ich vom verlag bezahlt
werden oder so mehr wird halt
umsatzfaktor man den clever bord bei der
buchwert und dann abhängig machen
magst du bücher überhaupt ja mag ich
aber konkreter es besser wenn er
büchermarkt und wenn der kontrakt noch
die lieber mag dann fahre hier einfach
mal magst du denn von crafter buchfrage
zeichnet ist nein aber ich mag den
crafter sehr gerne mein buch marke
glaube ich gar nicht frage erst mal hast
du mein buch also ob er es besitzt doch
habe ich okay alles klar hast du mein
buch also ob er es
hast das buch nein hast du mich hasst es
nicht nein ich hasse dich nicht lieber
clever bot nein du liebst pink ja wie
heißt du eigentlich weil wenn er meint
dass er mein nachbar ist habe ich schon
mal gesagt
daran kann ich mich jetzt eigentlich nie
erinnern ich möchte dich als nachbar
kennen punkt punkt punkt hast du gefühle
für mich manchmal und ein herz mal
schauen was okay hast du mal gesehen
nein
welche farbe hat meine hose kpg
nein mein kleid ist nicht klar was für
klein losgesagt hose möchte endlich zu
senden und es liegt mir lieber clever
bot möchtest du wenn du willst ok alles
klar
ok dann mache ich das liebst du mich
dann fragezeichen was machst du clever
wort ist super einem ablenken ich rede
gerade mit einem ablenker punkt okay was
schreibt er dazu dann beantworte bitte
meine frage dass ich dir kein
wunschkonzert du beantwortest meine
fragen beantworte meine frage und ich
beantworte die eine frage dann antworte
ich halt ich mache gerade nichts soll
ich dir eine geschichte erzählen ja mach
mal kommen dann wenn wir mal gespannt
was uns der klar wird okay es war einmal
ein mädchen ende ein buch unter gefallen
was kannst du eigentlich